et cyril hanouna vous le savez aussi ce
qu'on aime c'est les vannes et il ya
quelques spécialistes de la punchline
donc on va faire le world du meilleur
valeur du poste 2019
regardez les nommer
cyril hanouna donc touche pas à mon
poste tour à tour si vous avez le
moindre réponse vous rester en course
sinon c'est l'élimination et bien sûr
ceux qui sont éliminés sont éliminés
pour le restant de l'année est venue
faire à ce qu'on appelle une aire à
d'accord est rare qu'est ce que c'est
rachid arhab sugar sammy dans la france
a un incroyable talent
[Applaudissements]
le char
ouais je n'ai pas été touchée mais
rageant parce que je fais un petit
garçon
et laurent baffie dans la grande d'arc à
moi je me débrouille avec ça pour quand
même que ma vie soit la moins compliquée
possible vous l'avez le vous j'ai
parcouru j'ai pas fini parce que j'avais
déjà huit ou neuf livres à dire hélas
colorier 2 avant que tu nous donnes le
gagnant antoine je rappelle qu'on va se
retrouver à 21h15 ce sera donc d'abord
aux i way tapantes tapant sur cissé
21h06 dont je tais je quitte la chaîne
je quitte tous ses choix
si oui bah oui oui je quitte un
engagement public un oui je quitterais
de faure michel blanc hakim gemini je
voudrais vous remercier d'avoir été
chauffeur et michel ça a été un bonheur
de vous rencontrer ça fait des années
que je vous rencontre et c'est la
première fois qu'on se voie et voilà je
suis très heureux de vous voir j'espère
pas merci à renouveler merci à l'est moi
je dis que c'est moi le bail au web pour
que dès qu'on vous voulez que des
poudriers akin toi de toi tu es chez toi
tu viens tu rentres tu fais tous les
structures pas et je vais suivre les
césars à fond et je vais suivre les
entrées de films et à chaque fois que tu
passeras les 500000 je ferai une grande
fête ici non pas sûr qu'ils avaient à
chaque fois blessant son ami je ferai
une grande fête je te lis bien sûr et
certain
si la série bord études faire les
fanions et non plus trois vannes un peu
pourri qui l'avez vous vous êtes
autonome et en fait ouais j'sais pas
comment une prime moyenne soit ces
tarbas bâtards louvre police qui vous
vous n'avez pas été fan des 3 si j'ai
bien aimé je suivais resserrer ce
garçonnet qui dès qu'ils essaient et
cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
chocolat
sachant quoi
je
les crues consensus
composé sur moi il m'a eu
je n'ose pas lui dire qu'elle compte au
moins
[Musique]